The first answer to keep snooping sys admins from knowing
everyone's passwords. That's actually correct. That's there's no reason why you
as a website owner should, you know, know your user's passwords.
Or maybe there are a few reasons but not very good
ones. And this, you know, eliminates a whole, you know, issue
that you have to worry about. Because people often use the
same password for many websites. This also correct answer. I wish
people didn't, and you may think well, it's not my problem.
But, if you're accepting user's passwords you do have
a bit of a moral obligation to keep them safe.
Because no matter how loud you yell and scream,
people are going to continue to use the same password,
allows the passwords for many websites. If the database
is compromised the passwords are reasonably safe, this is also
true. They're not completely safe of course. You know
they have your database now, they know what those hashes
are they can figure out the passwords in some potentially huge amount of time.
But it's a lot safer than just giving them the passwords. And if you
don't, you will regret it. This is also true. And I'm going to share
a tale of, of me goofing on this and how much I regret it.